now the dating the dating agency this is
a bride into life I'm seriously get this
book yeah he's a mold was it was the
dating agency before the weddings are
off to the west it was actually after
after yeah this is a lovely thing well
they weren't lovely but that we don't
have them anymore this was you were you
were filming people's video profiles
right before the online companies of
dating and all that sort of thing you
actually had to go into an office and
this company was called great
expectations and it was actually very
very successful and they would match
people up and basically you would go in
you would take a picture you would write
out a profile of who you are and then
you would have a short video tape so
that men or women can watch someone and
go I like I like the feel of this person
this feels genuine or whatever and so I
would conduct the videotape interviews
and I'd have a little secret button and
most of them would come in and go well I
like walks on the beach and I'm very
romantic and I like to cook at home and
it's like okay calm down yeah we don't
this is not gonna work because you're
trying too hard just relax so I would
usually tell a joke and then they would
laugh and I'd push the button when
they're laughing and start the tape and
then said do you have a joke and they
would say something or tell the joke not
knowing they were being taped and a
fifty seconds later I'd say that's it
we're done and we just wanted to get a
little snippet of who they really are
and it really worked but I don't know
because again like you know there's all
the apps and things now people have
forgotten this world of these things
somebody very handily did a little
montage of men who done these things so
I don't know if you've directed any of
these it's quite perfect I think we'll
see the name of the company I can't know
what it's called here we go
[Music]
okay early to bed early to rise makes a
woman healthy wealthy and wise that's
why you're wiser than me it's Steven
memories I'm an executive by day and a
wild man by night you've probably
already noticed that I have incredibly
blue eyes hi my name is Phil most my
friends call me Big Phil
okay so at we thought it said your the
acute beam here you've seen here so if
we if we replay the little the opening
there I wonder if you could show the
boys how help might be done okay so here
we go hi I'm Brian I'm 60 in it if you
like threesomes just remember I like
Malcolm in the Middle
[Applause]
I'm Eddie I'm 34 and if you're looking
for a fantastic Beast
hi I'm Benedict but you can call me Big
Ben I'm summer over 30 if you're feeling
a bit strange the doctor will see you
now
[Applause]
that is going to guarantee that we will
all have state single
[Applause]
[Music]